.
- Ils font partie intégrante
du paysage montréalais.
Et c'est justement le problème,
n n n la Chambre de commerce.
MICHEL LEBLANC, président
Chambre commerce Mtl Métropol.
- C'est comme si... on a admis
que Montréal est en train de se
définir par des cônes orange
- Blocage minimum,
c'est l'objectif que
cette étude veut aider à
atteindre.Et on en est loin.
Dans le grand périmètre du
centre-ville, en une année,
94 % des rues ont été au
moins partiellement entravées.
La Chambre pointe notamment
le fait que plus de neuf permis
d'occupation de l'espace public
sur 10 sont octroyés
- On peut se poser la question :
ça génère 24 millions de revenus
à la ville. Donc là, peut-être
qu'on a une situation où j'ai
tendance aussi à voir ça comme
un poste de revenu.AuAuAuAu risr
la vie des Montréalais et
des visiteurs...
MANUELA GOYA, V-P, dév. aff.
publiques, Tourisme Montréal- -,
les trottoirs qui sont souvent
des culs-de-sac, les cônes
abandonnés.
- Un cul-de-sac comme celui-ci,
en plein centre-ville, où
les abords du chantier
soulèvent des questions.
GLENN CASTANHEIRA directeur
général, Montréal Centre-ville
- C'est à se demander si c'est
une oeuvre d'art contemp....
Je veux dire, c'est rendue
une blague!
- L'étude suggère de modifier
la règlementation et de
l'adapter à la réalité
de Montréal.
- Il n'est pas normal que dans
un des quartiers les plus denses
au Québec, quand on fait un tout
petit trou sur le trottoir,
il nous faut une cinquantaine
de cônes oranges, ça n'asososos.
Il va vraiment falloir
moderniser ces règles-là.
- D'autant qu'un décompte
a démontré que plus d'
cône sur quatre est orphelin,
tout simplement abandonné.
Parmi les solutions évoquées
pour réduire l'impact des
chantiers : les inscrire dans
une plateforme pour les
coordonner. Elle existe déjà,
mais...
- La réalité, c'est que c'est
une participation facultative,
puis la réalité, c'est que
les chiffres qu'on a, c'est
que c'est 6 à 7 % des
chantiers qui sont intégrés
dans l'exercice.ilililililille a
ce printemps un sommet sur
les chantiers.
DOMINIQUE OLLIVIER présidente du
comité exécutif de Montréal
- On va asseoir tout le monde
ensemble, s'entendre sur
des normes, et surtout, faire
en sorte que tous les secteurs
se sentent responsabilisés.
- Pour mettre fin à ce que
l'étude appelle la frustration
perpétuelle.
Ici Mathieu